TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
THE CMT MUSIC AWARDS WERE
TONIGHT HONORING THE BEST IN
COUNTRY MUSIC WHICH IS USUALLY
THE WORST IN REGULAR MUSIC.
BUT, NOW, LISTEN, I AM FROM THE
SOUTH, I LOVE REAL COUNTRY MUSIC
BUT WITH TAYLOR SWIFT, IT IS NOT
EVEN REDNECK THINK MORE, IT IS
LIKE PINK BUBBLE GUM NECK, WE
GOTTA PUT THE RED BACK IN RED
NECK AND THE REDNECK BACK INTO
MUSIC, SO THE HASHTAG TONIGHT =
IS #REDNECKASONG. SO EXAMPLES
MIGHT BE:
MULLET THE BLUE SKY OR LINE
DANCING QUEEN, OR 99 PROBLEMS
AND THE JEWS ARE ONE.
>> I AM GOING TO PUT 60-SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK AND GO.
>> ARDEN.
>> I COOKED A SQUIRREL AND I
LIKED IT.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
>> TIM.
>> WAR PIGS OF NORTHERN
AGGRESSION.
>> Chris: VERY GOOD.
ARDEN HE.
>> I AM THE WAL-MART.
>> Chris: POINTS. YES, BOBBY.
>> HOTEL 6 CALIFORNIA.
>> Chris: ARDEN.
>> WHAT DOES THE FOXWORTHY SAY.
>> Chris: YES POINTS. ARDEN
>> SMELLS LIKE TEEN PREGNANCY.
>> Chris: I LAUGHED AND THEN I
THOUGHT ABOUT IT LITERALLY AND
I GOT UNCOMFORTABLE.
YES, TIMOTHY.
>> I AM DREAMING OF A WHITES
ONLY CHRISTMAS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BOBBY.
>> MISUSING MY RELIGION.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES.
TIMOTHY.
>> MUTTON COMPARES TO YOU.
>> Chris: NICE, POINTS.
ARDEN.
>> YOU SHOOK THE BABY ALL NIGHT
LONG.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TIMOTHY.
>> DARK SIDE OF THE MOONSHINE.
>> Chris: OH, NICE! I LIKE
THAT ONE.